first I want to start by saying how much
I love to this movie it is just
fantastic and the one thing I took away
from it was that I could never be an
astronaut there's just nothing in my
bones that could do it
I'm not heroic it's just it's amazing
what these men did and women and I'm
just curious for the two of you do you
think you have what it takes to actually
do what's portrayed in this film no no
no the miracle I can't drive a car no
you're right I mean I
yeah the there were so many moments in
this film where I felt the same way as
you did and it's it's a I think it's to
Damian's credit that he wanted to focus
on the humanity of the story because
it's sort of you know it reveals these
kind of special qualities of these
people you know that that that that make
them so unique you know it's a certain
kind of person like Neal for instance
who is a test pilot who's gonna
knowingly get into a plane that's never
been flown push it to its breaking point
just to further our understanding of
aeronautics you know I'm not that way
that's a certain person and that's not
me yeah I mean the thing also is that
Neal was a man of like a few words very
private what's it like you're both
playing real people what's it like
what's the first thing you do maybe to
like break in because I've spoken to
some actors that say like it's the first
thing that you figure out and all of a
sudden it gets so much easier is it do
you find that to be the case I think
when you're playing people that you
really respect and admire and lots of
other people do as well and also people
that their children are so heavily
involved in
every element of the film I think you
never I never certainly got to the point
where I thought I've cracked her I just
definitely felt that I that I every day
I was kind of high for aware and hyper
vigilant with myself but I'm not getting
lazy and not taking it for granted and
kind of remembering Janet really and
always questioning whether she would
make the same decision that I was making
I think it was for me the most helpful
part was having Neil Sons be so involved
you know they and and Neil's sister June
for instance you know and and and
friends and family and co-workers you
know just just just in all-hands-on-deck
approach from everyone that knew Neil
and Janet to try and give us as much
context as possible so that we could try
and and shed some light onto the people
that they knew so well you know totally
I'm a huge fan of Damian's work you've
obviously worked with him before
this is your first time can you share
what it's like behind the scenes working
with him and maybe what would surprise
people about his filmmaking process I
don't know what would surprise people
because not sure what I'm not sure what
the impression is of of him you know I
feel like he's sort of I think what's
look there are many things that make him
so you know you need unique in his in
his ability but I think this the way
he's able to manage the scale of the
sets and the environments that he works
in and still keep the environment
feeling very you know small and personal
and creative it's really unique you know
I mean at any given moment on this film
there was just giant LED screens and
he's coordinating you know whatever
would be happening outside the window at
any given moment he could have used
green screen he didn't that they're
coordinating that with the gimbal and
the capsules that we were working in at
any given moment and the sequence was
just so much for him to keep track of
and yet he's able to do that and have
you know equal focus to the performances
and to the small sort of you know
intimate details at the film as well
yeah I think he can do the technical and
the poetic at the same time quite often
in the same scene which is pretty
amazing
on that note again movies fantastic
thank you so much for your time Thanks
[Music]
[Music]